if an airplane goes through the air
faster than the speed of sound you get a
what get a boom a sonic boom okay boom
okay so now what happens if a particle
travels through a medium
faster than the speed of light
um the entire universe implodes
on itself so here's the thing and we all
get sucked into a
oblivion
[Music]
this is star talk
cosmic queries edition i got chuck nice
with me can't do that without chuck
chuck how you doing man well that's that
has
that's not true oh actually it's not
true that's right we've had a lot of you
haven't you have done this without chuck
that's for sure i've had guest co-host
for chuck because chuck sometimes is a
busy man and you don't have time for us
that's how that works okay well that's
not true either
so chuck uh a little while ago we did an
entire cosmic queries on cosmic
collisions
which has a very rich tapestry of
phenomena and objects in the universe
that go celestial banging
in the night and in fact of the
portfolio of public talks that i give
that is the title of one of them cosmic
collisions
so if a city invites me to their theater
to give a public talk
and they they get the list of things i
can talk about cosmic collisions is
frequently selected in that list so
chuck you you've solicited questions
from our patreon members and so
i guess it's all about collisions so
bring it on
okay let's uh let's jump right into this
this is a
christopher bax
and christopher says dr tyson and
darling chuck
well christopher
thank you christopher
you know
you really know way to a man's heart
i am susceptible to flattery
uh sometimes people refer to photons
as not experiencing time from that
photons vantage point the moment it's
emitted from a source and the moment it
hits something are simultaneous
does that mean that the object a photon
impacts
is deterministic
let's say for example i see a photon
from a star one million light years away
from my perspective
i just happened to be there when i
looked up and the light hit my eye but
from the photons perspective it hits the
lens of my eye at the exact moment it
was emitted does that mean that i had to
be in that spot at that time because i
was
pre-destined
to be hit by that my boy's getting deep
he's good he's just sweating oh
philosophical also he says at the end of
that um
are you a fan of sativa
marijuana or
no i'm joking
i just put that
so
so if we think of photons
hitting their destination as a collision
perfectly happy to think of it that way
so if you didn't happen to stand up and
and stand and look up
when the photon hit your eye and you
like
stepped to the side
the photon would then hit the leaf or
the grass or the mountainside or the the
beach it'll it'll just be instantaneous
with that
so
what you're thinking to yourself is that
the photon
when it's emitted sees your eye
and then just goes straight into your
eye in that instant but no thirty
thousand well however many thousands of
years do pass and things can happen
before the photon hits its destination
so
so
i guess what you're wondering is does
the photon have an awareness
an advanced awareness of where it's
going to hit since no time elapses
that's kind of what you think what are
you saying there i think
is that what you think yeah i think so i
mean that's one
version of predestination i mean the
other predetermined outcome would be
that it was set before the photon left
its origin yeah yeah but i'm just saying
so so the three of us are here looking
up and we're on some kind of rotating
wheel right and so
okay who's going to get the photon and
who's not and the photon already knows
at the moment it was emitted
whose eyeball it's going to go into
so that's a way i have to think about
that some more
yes because at as far as the photon is
concerned
that's the way it has to be because it's
it actually comes into existence
at the time
destination correct correct and if
that's so it has to be that way for the
photon if that's the case
so i have to i have to think about that
some more
yeah that's a good one all right that's
a yeah i mean because that's i mean
it's truly philosophical in nature but
what he made me think about yeah is i'm
well actually what you made me think
about in reference to his question
are all the photons
that
lose out
on being seen
because they land on some stupid beach
okay
well i lament i i wrote about this long
ago because i felt it i was on
mountaintops getting data for my phd and
i thought to myself the photons that
come to my telescope and go into my
detector and go into my data
are serving to have the universe
understand itself
right because we humans are products of
this universe
and what if that photon missed my
telescope and just slammed into the side
of the mountain
what a what a wasted trip
that's what i'm saying
that's sad
i just traveled 40 000 years
to be a part of driftwood driftwood
driftwood or you're on a beach and you
hit someone's buttocks who's who's
sunbathing you know oh man yeah
exactly
it's like i spent all this time
i passed i passed neptune i passed
uranus only to hit your ass
you passed your anus to hit your head
no so so i
um yeah i think about the photons and
how about the ones that miss earth
entirely and just keep moving through
space
most of space is empty and so the
universe is filled with photons
crisscrossing through the night and the
day
and so yeah i have to think more deeply
about the life of a photon
all right now that you said to
crisscross now i gotta i gotta just
pick up on that
so two light sources two photons in the
emptiness of space yes
crisscross yeah
but they can't hit each other no they
can they can cross each other they're
just waves at that level so here's the
thing
i got into a twitter fight
mild twitter fight with brian cox who's
kind of my counterpart over in the uk
not brian cox the actor but brian cox
the physicist or he's done a lot of pbs
uh bbc tv in fact he's on tour he
occasionally tours through the united
states he's got a whole universe show
okay this latest one is called event
horizon i think but the so i got into a
twitter fight because i said
that lightsabers in star wars
um you know they could cut things and do
damage if they're high enough power but
they can't bounce off each other because
light waves pass through the columns
that's like two lasers they'll just pass
through each other it's not like
ghostbusters right wow
don't cross streams don't cross the
streams okay no it's whatever we don't
know what happens if that's what happens
in ghostbusters but it's not a problem
with light beams so here's my point if
uh so i say this and then and then brian
cox comes well actually if the if
they're made of gamma rays the gamma
rays two gamma rays have a probability
of interacting with each other and not
passing through each other they have
high enough energy to do this
and then you could simulate what could
be a sort of a bouncing effect between
two swords two laser swords and so i had
to i conceded
on international twitter
that i got out geeked in that in that
tweet
but wouldn't you both be fried wouldn't
the two sword fighters be fried
from the gamma rays or they'll turn into
the hulk you know there's other issues
yeah yeah yeah that's true that's the
least of my concerns about the absence
of physics in star wars just make that
clear yeah all right i said yeah i said
it
all right give me some more
all right let's go with fred lombardo
fred lombardo says good day dr tyson
since your numerous references to the
idea that dark matter should be called
fred
which is my name oh i have thought of
myself as dark matter my question though
since the fred particle seems to elude
scientists is it possible that the
particle is actually a particle of
time itself
this would account for it's making up a
majority of what seems to construe the
universe and explain why it a particle
has never been found uh
loved the show and okay please say hi to
please say hi to chuck
so a particle of time
so that's right
um
see time is a coordinate
just a space is a coordinate so
you'd have to have analog too is there a
particle of space
that can move
through space the way a particle of time
might move through time and i don't
think you can do that
um there there is the smallest unit of
space
okay it's called a plank length
plank it's very small
and
and the smallest unit of time
would be the time it takes light to
cross a plank length
so in a sense space and time are
quantized
effectively voxels
that that's volume pixels voxels of
space and time in the universe but
they're not separately particles in that
sense by the way i just thought of
calling them fred only because we don't
know what it is so i don't know what it
is that that's all it's really you know
what it literally is it's dark gravity
to call it dark matter implies it's
matter and we don't even know that it's
a good bet that it would be
if you're a betting person that's uh
that's the odds are
in your favor but
so no i'm not voting for a particle of
time that by the way what's that movie
there's a movie where you could collect
time
and then
add it to your life
yes um that was with justin timberlake
yes i had justin timberlake that's
correct get the young lady's name um but
yeah um you could buy time time was the
commodity time
there was no other
um
there was nothing else of value in the
world except time and it was the
currency for everything right and the
rich people oh and the rich people had
all of it and the more time you had the
longer you lived well don't the rich
people have always have more of
everything that everyone else wants
otherwise what's the point of being rich
that's so true that's it that's it
that's
that's
all i'm saying so so in that one maybe
you can think of those as time particles
i have a time particle and i hand it to
you
and then you accrue the time but it's
not clear why that would have anything
to do
with
gravity with dark gravity correct or
even the acceleration of the universe
so yeah there you go
well there you go yeah yeah hey nothing
wrong with uh trying to find a little
self-hype in dark gravity fred fred
nothing wrong with that fred
and did you know there was was it there
was a dc
uh
superhero
briefly introduced i think it was dc not
marvel uh who was
who's named fred
and that's his sort of regular name but
his superhero name was dark matter
and so
i didn't know you didn't know you're
just making that
in my astronomy bizarre public talk
i i talk about fred the dark matter
by the way i didn't discover that myself
someone heard me calling dark matter
fred is a did you know and then they
showed me a picture and they said it's
in a picture it's fred with all of the
properties you know it's like what are
your parameters you know your origin
story what are your powers uh what are
your power limits and what's your
civilian name this is dark matter and
his civilian name is
fred
wow first of all
uh that has to be dc
um it's probably dc because he's got
this guy because a civilian name right
yeah because uh marvel would never make
any superhero name fred
and no offense to you fred
but
that's cold no take that yeah no i'm not
truck no because
nobody goes just like help me friend
no no his superhero name is dark matter
that's my point oh oh yeah well still
even even still i mean like okay think
of it let's think of it now for a second
he'll be fred
right but no think of this
bruce wayne
yeah clark kent
yeah peter parker
all right fred farter
far
fred what fred no fred doesn't work all
right
all right fred doesn't
sorry anyway we'll send you complaints
to the
yeah yeah complaint chat room right okay
yeah marvel they have good they have
good names okay here we go this is
justin hansen greetings esteemed
dr tyson
my son tucker who just turned 11
recently asked me whether reducing the
temperature of a radioactive element to
absolute zero would give the appearance
of the half-life being reduced due to
relativistic effects you are lying no 11
year old asked this damn question
who the hell you think you fool it just
say you want to know this justin
that's all you got to do hey dr tyson
pass it off on his kids yeah i got a i
got a question i was thinking about for
a long time you know it has to do with
absolute zero and uh
you gotta be kidding me anyway
eleven-year-old eleven-year-old tucker
wants to know okay eleven-year-old okay
tucker is the next superhero nemesis
yes super superhero right
what is he building in his basement all
right we have to we must find that out
immediately send authorities and it
ain't good
i'll tell you this right now if tucker
wants to know if a radio l-active
element at absolute zero would give the
appearance of the half-life being
reduced due to the relativistic effects
you know okay i say move out now because
technically blow up your house
move out now yeah move out now
because tucker is blowing up jake while
you can
there you go all right so that's an
excellent question so as as you know
everything slows down as you drop the
temperature of things but when i say
everything everything chemical slows
down
mm-hmm
chemical things slow down so the rate at
which chemical reactions
under uh unfold
it goes to about half the rate for every
10 degrees celsius
so
that's why for example it's important
that your refrigerator
is as cold as you can get it but not
freezing
so that whatever bacteria are growing in
your food that would ultimately turn it
green and smell nasty you want to delay
that
all right it's not that food is good
until it's nasty the food is
systematically getting nasty until it
hits some nose threshold or color
threshold that you have held for it
right unless it's avocado in which case
five minutes is all that will last no
matter what until it turns brown on the
top right you take it out five minutes
later it's a rotten mess no you put some
put some lemon juice on it lime juice is
good it'll work all right i'm going to
try that what did you try you didn't
know this
no dude
is that for real have you never met a
mexican in your life
you got to get out more um you know what
now you're embarrassing me because i'm
going to tell you the truth
i don't know any mexican you don't
actually don't know
i'm in new york man all my friends are
puerto rican okay yeah my friends are my
family i got friends and my family
they're all puerto ricans
or dominican if they look like me
they're dominican
all right all right so
so for every 10 degrees so that's why
food go spoils faster if it's not in the
refrigerator
you put it in the refrigerator delays it
but it will all still go bad all right
according to this calculation for every
10 degrees celsius
it's
doubles the rate at which something will
happen or if cooler it'll have the rate
keep doing this down all the way to
absolute zero you could basically keep
food forever
forever in terms of bacteria that would
be growing on it you have other issues
related to the molecular integrity of
the food itself
so it can start losing its texture but
that's not because bacteria we're eating
at is because the molecules themselves
are unstable here's the point
the moment you go nuclear
then all the things that apply to atoms
and molecules no longer apply
whole other sets of forces dominate
in the nuclear regime
and so if you cool things the nucleus
doesn't give a rat's ass it will still
decay at exactly the rate that you had
measured for it at any other temperature
if you want to slow down the rate
what you do is you speed up the molecule
ooh
okay
you speed up the decaying particle
yeah right you speed it up put it in a
particle accelerator
send it
nine tenths the speed of light 99 100
the speed of light and it will slow down
the decay rate by the exact amount
predicted by einstein's special theory
of relativity aha because anything
moving at the speed of light time itself
slows down for that well at the speed of
light to stop so you get closer to stop
stop saying the closer you get to the
speed of light the more the physical
watch
that you know the timepiece that the
particle's wearing on its wrist it's
everything about it everything
everything including its very nature
this probabilistic thing that it will
decay
and that's why you say it's time itself
that's slowing down not
and it's a measurement it's not the
measurement itself it's it's the thing
the thing itself so you're going to look
at your clock and and you're you slow
down your brain slow down the clock
slows down you don't know anything it's
slowing down you don't know anything has
slowed so the particle has no idea that
it took
longer for it to decay
in its own reference frame but to our
reference frame it takes longer so if
you want to relativistically affect
particles that are decaying with
half-lives you just simply accelerate
them or put them in a very different
gravity field
that'll slow them down too slow them
down too wow okay hey
tucker
air quotes
tucker let me just say buddy
you are you're an amazing kid tucker
okay let me just
you keep at this tucker and whatever
you're building in that basement when
you unleash it on the world just
remember chuck nice is your friend chuck
said something nice to you okay that's
right
just remember the black man who told you
you were special
well you're demanding your 1 billion
dollars
in ransom that's right
so so chuck you're agreeing to be his
sidekick you're you're
agreeing to that all the way yeah listen
without a doubt
all right all right chuck we just
finished out that segment all right when
we come back more cosmic queries on
cosmic collisions when star talk returns
chuck we're back cosmic queries on
cosmic collisions of all kinds small
blurred medium large universe everything
and you got the questions from our
patreon members so give keep keep them
coming
all right let's do it uh
this is don lane
uh that sounds like a person from a
old time movie anyway um no don lane
would be a a game show host
oh you're right that's right that's
against your host name i'm don
that's right it's cosmic collisions with
john lane yeah all right here we go this
is he goes
do we watch too much tv chuck is this a
problem i don't know it could be you
know
don lane says hello dr tyson lord nice
could moons of outer planets have been
born from inner rocky bodies that may
have broken off of molten rocky planets
in the early formation of the solar
system could this be proven or would it
change our current understanding of how
our solar system was formed so
i love it i love it i love it okay so
let's look at the solar system for the
moment only once we had sufficient
computing power were we able to show
because we started saying oh uh our
solar system is probably representative
and we have some small rocky planets up
close and some big gaseous ones far out
and some other gaseous ones a little
farther out and some comets and
asteroids why think that we look
different right as a first pass when we
started collecting data on exoplanets oh
my gosh oh there's like a jupiter
orbiting as close to its host star as
mercury is to our sun or even closer and
there's all kinds of variation that no
one expected
okay so all we can say is that there is
no standard solar system star system
that first second
when our computer models got good enough
we would start we would
create solar systems you say okay let's
start with 30 planets and see what
happens oh they settle out
some planets get
get swung into the sun others get eaten
by the bigger planets and others settle
peacefully into their orbits
so it is highly likely that any star
system with eight or ten planets in it
started with two or three times that
many objects
okay so
so
yes now
if you take that down to a moon system
like jupiter and i lost count of how
many moons it has 60 i don't remember um
wow there are things you can yeah it's
the ton of moons there are things you
can know if the moon is it looks like an
idaho potato
right
then it was never big enough
for its gravity to shape it into a
sphere
okay
okay because
could it i'm just just following up
could it have just been captured by that
orbit
yeah no no yes but wherever it formed
i'm just saying it was never big enough
to make a sphere out of itself so it
stayed as a craggy state
okay okay that's it that's right second
if you do see craggy chunks of rock out
there in orbit should we call it a moon
there's a lot of stuff like for example
mars has how many moons do you know how
many moons bars have i don't i have two
moons it has two moons phobos and deimos
and they are the lamest moons i i have
no
they look like idaho potatoes one is the
size of manhattan right it's like no
no don't make me call these moons i'm
sorry why are you moon shaming mars
god that's that's cold casting shade on
mars
no if i gotta be you know i know i have
some history there with pluto and stuff
but pluto was at least big enough to be
a sphere all right as is its moon its
biggest moon sharon was big enough to be
a sphere so there's the sphere club and
then there's the craggy chunks of rock
club and there's a very clear
distinction between the two of them so
things you can learn
when you see moons around other planets
is well was it is it massive enough to
have made it into a spherical shape
if it's craggy it's probably a chunk
broken off of some other larger thing
that was a sphere okay
in a collision
so that's another thing you can tell and
also there's some moons where one half
of the moon looks really different from
the other half
as though something collided into that
half and then took its own shape
relative to the side that is 180 degrees
away and a third kind of moon i forgive
me i forgot the name the famous moon
where it looks like some piece of other
asteroid
collided and got stuck in it because if
you look at the terrain it's really
really really different over in one
section compared with another section
and it looks angular and it's like
somebody just mashed it in there and so
there's a lot to learn from the
topography
of moons provided they don't have
weather systems that erase the record of
the collisions you experienced in life
so you take a look at the surface of the
moon it's been hit by some meteors right
how about earth how many craters have
you seen on earth a few
all right but we're right next to the
moon in the in the in the stream of
impactors
were not for our atmosphere and our
weather
and other erosive corrosive forces we
would look just like the moon
well thank god just we have those
weather and
atmosphere just like the moon you want
to thank god that's fine because we're
well
i mean well thank thank atmosphere okay
atmosphere i'll thank atmosphere and
i'll thank weather okay because no you
can thank god i don't have a problem you
thanking god the moon is ugly the moon's
got an ugly face that's all i'm saying
you know
the moon is that's cosmic acne acne we
have ways of covering up the history of
that
of the scars
of having been slammed so
there's a whole
branch of geology and astronomy that has
merged as planetary geology basically
and these are folks who worry about this
all the time
excellent right yeah excellent question
man keep it going all right
uh this is our old buddy uh alejandro
reynoso okay
i am coming to you from monterey mexico
is it for monterey is he yeah he's from
montana oh oh cool so it's all there you
you're running the you're running the
gamut there okay go ahead
he says monterey with two r's by the way
correct that's correct yeah yeah the
monterey uh california i think is one r
but okay go on and then he says
hello
or should i say
that's not what he's saying
no he he says that okay okay go
he says if we
if we could see
how uh
if we could see it
how would the collision between two
black holes look like it i we actually
have seen that okay
but but then wait wait then he goes on
all right
how about three
some people just never satisfied yeah i
love it
oh that's great
okay uh you're not likely to get three
things to hit simultaneously
just you do the statistics on it it's
just not happening
you get two objects to collide and then
collide with the third object but to
have all three
collide with each other at the same time
is statistically
sufficiently unlikely to not really want
to waste your brain power on that but we
do
no we haven't photographed the collision
of two black holes but we know exactly
what it would look like because we
completely know the physics and the
geometry and the relativity of what's
going on and all you have to do is
google a youtube
video of
of uh
the black holes that collided
that ligo observed so what would be the
search on that good search for youtube
ligo colliding black holes
make sure it's youtube and then you'll
be a video and so you'll see the two and
what you'll see their effect on the
stars behind them
okay that's where the action is because
the space around the black holes are
distorted
and it brings things that are in a
different place in the background into a
new place in the foreground you have a
completely distorted circular images
of light around the black holes it is
what you see with those recently
released photos of black holes a one in
our own galaxy and one in another galaxy
called m87 you see a ring of light and
then a darkness in the center
so that darkness is basically the shadow
of the black hole because no light is
coming from it and what's around it is
all the light from distant beyond it
that is collected into this ring which
is with the effect that black holes have
on their environments so you check it
out and you watch it and then you see
this ripple which is the gravitational
wave
that got emanated on collision and
that's what we waited 1.3 billion years
to detect when we finally turned on the
laser interferometer gravitational wave
observatory
ligo check it out
it's beautiful
that is
amazing it is beautiful and so now what
let's say we turned it on
right after einstein theorized
that
these gravity waves would happen
would we have then seen them okay no no
right right so so here's the thing um
einstein wrote down an equation
for the stimulated emission of radiation
in atoms
and
it was a small paper in quantum physics
and
you had to that was in 1916 or 17 and
then you had to wait until 1957.
so that's 40
40 years later where someone uses those
equations to invent a laser
okay the l in ligo stands for laser
nobody's detecting anything without the
laser here okay so einstein predicts
gravitational waves he he presages the
discovery of the laser and then we use
lasers to measure the existence of
gravitational waves which means einstein
was a badass that's all it's just pure
and simple and he got a nobel prize in
1921 for nothing i just said
okay
and that's and that's when you know
you're the goat
okay
greatest of all time yeah when they when
they yeah yeah so what we learned was we
you know if you turn on the machine and
you discover colliding black hole a week
later
you say boy we got lucky or maybe these
things are happening more frequently
than you previously thought so right now
i forgot the numbers and dozens of
colliding black holes that we have data
on
so yeah had we turned it on back when
einstein did this we would have found
them
but we where technology and computing
wasn't sufficient at the time to have
come anywhere near a detection
you have to wait most of the century
we're gonna take a quick break when we
come back to the third and final segment
of cosmic queries
cosmic collisions on star talk
we're back third and final segment
cosmic queries cosmic collisions
is one of my favorite subjects i talk
about this forever chuck i don't know
how many questions we're going to get
through and this is our second
installment of cosmic collisions all
right yes
there's probably a third one in there
but we'll give you all a break okay
so chuck i was i was surfing the tv and
there you were your smiley face on nat
geo in disney plus
host of brain games
walks
we're all proud of you jeff well thanks
you know
you're not just any random comedian out
there you you care about being smart and
we love that we love that well thank you
and that is true i appreciate that yeah
all right here we go this is heps from
new zealand
right he says hello dr tyson what's up
funny man my name i think i'm the funny
man uh i'm not sure the way
i think it's it's a placeholder for
whoever is in your slot yeah exactly
that's what i'm saying
that's all right
all right here we go this is woody he
says hello neil lord nice you know how
the melting point of water lowers under
pressure
could two bodies of ice join together
in a collision
and what kind of force would it need to
make that party trick by whacking the
joining ice cubes
uh
i did try clapping ice a few times while
writing this and no it did not work yeah
it doesn't work
woody did the experiment in anticipation
this is not a question is he's he's
calling you for confirmation
confirmation of his experiment all right
so
uh a fully solid object
occupies space
that
cannot be
encroached upon
unless something changes about that body
now we talked about this before with ice
it ice
when you freeze water it expands
right
so how do i compress an ice cube back to
its original volume you can't
unless the ice
melts under pressure and becomes water
again
right so you can't shrink the size of
ice without ice having to completely
change its molecular configuration okay
from from a lattice
for the ice down to a fluid which is
then water so no you can't take two ice
cubes and just merge them into one
object that that does not work but
that's true for any
solid homogeneous object by the way if
it's if the object has thrown air
bubbles in it or air holes yeah you can
sort of squeeze things in
in to that for sure but if it's if it's
a co if it's a uniform solid object it's
not happening
there you have it my friend you woody
you have your confirmation
yeah yeah and you did experiment i'm
delighted by the experiment it was a
success bro by the way there's some
things you can try to squeeze them
together and they won't intersect but
they'll flatten right if i take two sort
of small cubes of gold and i try to
squeeze them
i i won't succeed unless the gold has
permission to flatten in all directions
and on doing that you can flatten two
things if you squeeze them sure
yeah right
okay but the total volume of what you
flattened is the same
just so you know exactly yeah right okay
so this is amanda do any of these
collisions show any
type of light when they happen
i know that there's a lot of light being
shown either by stars or implosions
explosions that have already happened
years ago but maybe and maybe even
millennia ago oh i love it i love it
okay so
generally if you have a collision
there's a lot of energy that has to
manifest in some way
when you're manifesting energy often
that energy comes out in the form of
light of some kind
and
light can be any
manner any combination of the
electromagnetic spectrum if any of that
comes out as visible light you will see
a flash
there are people who have made a cottage
industry
of staring at the unilluminated
segment of the moon on any given night
okay so let's say it's a half moon in
the sky
they put their telescope on the half
that's not lit
and they carefully look for flashes of
light
and that's an impact that's a that's an
asteroid impact on the surface of the
moon
you're not going to notice it in the lit
side because it's too bright
all right so there's an entire cottage
industry of people who do this
right and and that impact where does the
kinetic energy of the object goes it
goes back into the object we discussed
this in part one of cosmic collisions i
think did we do that or is that in a
explainer well it's all one memory to me
now yeah
the collision of a high speed impact
right absolutely if you do that then it
explodes if that's sufficient energy
uh a lot like i said a lot of that
energy goes into infrared just to heat
and also to visible light now here's
something interesting okay
uh you know what happens if an airplane
goes through the air faster than the
speed of sound you get a what get a boom
it's a sonic boom okay boom okay so now
what happens if a particle
travels through a medium
faster than the speed of light
um the entire universe implodes
on itself so here's the thing and we all
get sucked into a
oblivion here's the thing
light moving through transparent objects
other than a vacuum travels slower than
the speed of than the speed of light in
a vacuum
did you know that in diamond
which is like one of the densest
transparent substances
light travels at 40 percent
of its speed in a vacuum
oh so diamonds are the breaks of light
yes they they they put on the breaks for
life they're slowing down and
the slower something moves in the medium
the more it refracts
when it bends going through it the
bigger is that angle so what makes
diamonds sparkle is light comes in in
one place
it multiply internally refracts and pops
out another place so it looks like the
diamond is sort of self-luminous
even though
you you don't think you had anything to
do with that
right so so now
when
you have a particle that goes through a
medium
and you accelerate it faster than the
speed of light in that medium
it creates
a flash of light
and was discovered by a russian called
cherenkov and it's called cherenkov
radiation c8 it's a light boom a light
boom yes not a sonic boom so like not a
sonic boom but a light boom that's
correct so cool correct that is i'm i
just love the diamond little fat toy
that's yeah yeah so all of this yeah
yeah so if you would if you were to put
particles through
um a diamond you get that effect at only
forty percent the speed of light and
just uh just a a a fast fact here
the light actually doesn't slow down
okay okay
we're getting we're getting creepy now
this is cool okay
okay so let's say you're trying to get
from one side of a party to the other
and it's crowded okay right
so what happens is you bump into
somebody so pardon me excuse me and then
in the space between you and the next
person you go at the speed of light but
then you hit the next world pardon me
excuse me
and then you go again
okay so when the light is interacting
with each of the particles in the
lattice
it has to get through that particle
and so that takes time whereas when it's
between the particles in the lattice
it's moving at the speed of light so you
add it all up there's a net slow down
before the beam comes out the other side
ah
i got you see
it's like hurtling
oh yeah okay
right like a hurdler heard
they're probably going their slowest
going when they're jumping over the
hurdle that's right but then they speed
right back up speed right back that's
very cool either that or a diamond is
just you know just like slow down baby
it's got the music
going to the earth's atmosphere from the
atmosphere into water and water into
glass glass into diamonds
so
any see-through medium or
any any see-through correct any
see-through medium that's cool man you
got it all right here we go here we've
got one more question time for one more
question
make it a good elaine
in the stars that's the name oh a-l-a-n
yes
no a-l-l-a-i-n elaine
elaine elaine okay yeah
hi dr tyson lord nice elaine from
montreal canada here uh can a meteor
impact create enough energy to
spontaneously
create particles thank you elaine oh
yeah
uh no
no that's it's all the energy of an
impact as as ferocious as it is
is not sufficient to influence
atoms
okay it's all stuff will break apart
you'll lose your molecules you might
even ionize some atoms but the nucleus
itself is way out of reach of the
energetics of a
of a mere
meteor impact so
yeah the regimes of the universe are
very distinct and separate by the way
that's why we can say with confidence
you know in the early days when we said
oh my gosh there's such a thing as an
atom and we found electrons
going around a nucleus maybe it's just a
small version of a solar system
and maybe it's just that all the way
down and all the way up wouldn't that be
cool like a nested doll
and then we went down there and we even
called the the the electrons in their
path around the nucleus we call them
orbit
right okay orbitals all right we got the
word from solar system so you go down
there and you find out no gravity has
nothing to do with what's going on it's
got nothing to do with newton it has to
do with quantum physics and all the
forces are different and no they're not
analogous
at all
and so same when you go very large when
you go very large
certain forces no longer manifest in the
same way
so you can't just scale things and claim
to get all everything the same way it
doesn't work that way
wow look at that that's
that's really you know the universe is a
tricky little something it's a tricky
it's tricky it's it would have been too
easy if everything just scaled right
yeah yeah that'd be just
way too easy
uh yeah but it's not that it's it's
harder which means physicists basically
have jobs
it's the trickiness that keeps us
employed exactly
exactly so chuck that's all we have time
for and so we got to call it quits there
always good to have you man
always a pleasure this is star talk
cosmic queries
collisions edition
our second installment we'll probably do
more but we'll give you a break from it
until
until you're feeling it and we start
getting requests i need more collisions
give them to me and we'll be there for
you on star talk neil degrasse tyson
keep looking
[Music]
you